what is happening there reject nation we
are going to watch ourselves some
gravity falls today episode eight of
season one if you could go ahead and
fall your finger to the like button that
would be great use the gravity to guide
your body towards the subscribe button
and get notified when a reaction for the
next gravity falls is up because we've
been enjoying the hell out of this show
also guys if you can go ahead and check
us out on patreon you can encompass your
parrot jack today uh cover a whole bunch
of shows over there as well thanks to
all the showing their support cover
full-length watch alongs for gravity
falls there and lastly thanks to the
boys of prepper for helping us edit down
these highlights that's so much
information just choose one of them to
do
come on what's with all this traffic and
why is it all
covered wagons
oh no no no
[Music]
uncle stan what's going on we got to get
out of here before it's too late
what's the thing they've circled the
wagons we're trapped
uh is it a rump springer
i got a good feeling about today what
what is it i don't know either they're
amish or it's some kind of settler's day
parade amish people don't go out to the
public they stay in the caves that's
right
and they kill animals with their bare
hands and wear the pelts
if any amish people are watching yeah so
not being real amish then i get out of
here
maybe you're a meta knight
and that's okay
gravity falls it used to be legal to
marry woodpeckers oh it's still legal ew
oh golly just remember if you come back
to the shack talking like these people
you're dead to me there's a carpetbagger
in the turnip cellar well hornswoggle my
haversack
howdy everyone you all know me pacifica
northwest great great granddaughter of
town founder nathaniel northwest that's
why she's special our first newcomer is
mabel
yeah let's get this pioneer day started
right guys usse
pioneer date is for serious people and
you look and act ridiculous i mean a
puppy playing basketball are you always
the silly
don't knock air bud you do have nachos
hanging from your ears hun
wow i'm embarrassed for you give her a
hand everybody
that's awkward
hey there uh donkey boy give me a hand
with my car huh here in 1863 i have
never heard tel aviv
oh
god come on steve you're a mechanic for
pete's sake cut me some slack slack i am
unfamiliar with this bold new expression
i'm getting dumber every second i'm here
are we gonna have to intervene here oh
look the constable what are you gonna do
throw me in ye stocks
ugh
my stamford i'm just a humble tomato
farmer selling his wares whoops i
dropped one oh whoops i dropped another
one
[Laughter]
i feel like i read something about
pacifica's great-great-grandfather
before in my investigations i recently
made a discovery nathaniel northwest may
not be the founder of gravity falls i
believe the proof of this secret is
buried somewhere on the enclosed
document oh no if only i could crack the
code
oh well if i help you crack this code
then nobody could ever call me silly
again yeah mystery twins i thought you
hated that i'm starting to accept it hmm
you have the internet now you could
crack stuff
oh no
sheriff blubs we've got a cold sepia
code sepia we can prove that nathaniel
northwest wasn't the real founder of
gravity falls it'll finally put pacifica
in her place and solving a mystery will
prove that i'm not silly i'm serious
[Music]
it's not egyptian
it's not numerology it's not wait of
course the triangle is the alchemist
symbol for flame lighting the parchment
on fire will reveal the secret message i
just made a hat
ah i just did something silly again oh
no wait they're lining up you folded it
into a map
this map should lead us to
the gravity falls museum of history you
realize what this means mabel we're
gonna have to break in
it's probably open those are your free
pioneer day passes
[Music]
so what is it anyway
oh it worked
[Music]
abstract it's huh down it's not abstract
it's upside down
have the targets been apprehended
negative but we're close i promise those
kids will never get past us
looking for this yeah yeah what do you
want money i want you to say that the
northwest family is the best family oh
sure you want that in writing
i did that with my mouth that's
impressive the statue must be pointing
to the next clue oh gross she's picking
my nose
mabel is solving all this
look out for booby traps ha booby traps
no
indiana jones
it's a treasure trove of historically
secretly things
[Music]
oh man ben franklin secretly was a woman
let it be here recorded that nathaniel
northwest fabled founder of gravity
falls was in fact a fraud the true
founder of gravity falls was sir lord
quentin trembley the third esquire who's
quentin trembley
oh no
oh wait gotcha
careful
who is quentin tremblay anyway see for
yourself
if you're watching this then you are one
of eight people in these united states
with clearance to view this information
in fact i myself will be shot as soon as
the filming is complete
of all of america's secrets the most
embarrassing was that of quentin trembly
the eighth and a half president of the
united states president eighth and a
half after winning the 1837 election in
a landslide
[Laughter]
he waged war on pancakes appointed six
babies to the supreme court and issued
the depancipation proclamation
he was kicked out of office and escaped
to an uncharted valley he named gravity
falls after plummeting into it at high
speed oh officially replaced by william
henry harrison as president and local
nobody nathaniel northwest as founder of
gravity fall
president tremblay's body are unknown
until now
whoa
you never noticed it we're just gonna
escort you and all this stuff back to
washington
you ain't coming back by the way
[Music]
i'm just a silly failure like that
embarrassing president what's his name
prove he's alive
it is i quentin trembley
[Laughter]
you're not silly you're brilliant and so
are you dear girl for following my clues
and freeing me from my delicious tombs
that's stephen colbert your silliness
solved the code that serious cops
couldn't crack in a hundred years
serious cups in order to get out of here
this is going to take the silliest plan
ever conceived i think i know who can
help you
[Music]
how about
that hole
we will leap through it
almost
there good
keep pushing
keep going
well we didn't fit through the hole
let's rebuild the box and try again
no
escape
let me
i gotta take me are you okay can i get
you anything edwin darling you are a
diamond in the rough
did you ever sign an official
resignation no sir i ate a salamander
and jumped out the window then
technically you're still legally the
president of the united states
technically as president of these
several united states i hereby order you
to pretend none of this ever happened
and go on a delightful vacation
mabel as thanks i'd like to make you an
official u.s congressman
legalizing everything
go mabel i'm voting for you i see your
car is stuck in the mud enjoy walking
home aren't you gonna tell her about her
eight-grade aunt paul gray you know what
dipper i've got nothing to prove i've
learned that being silly is awesome
no
prove it
nathaniel northwest didn't found gravity
falls and your whole family is a sham
what revenge is underrated that felt
awesome
just know that i'll always be right here
on the negative 12 bill
whoa
this is worthless
trembling away
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it works so what's with the top hat
i'm a congressman pardon me you are
officially pardoned
semantic joke mabel away
yeah
i'm okay esteemed gentleman of the
united states of babies i implore you to
rethink your decision
yes
this is a courtroom i this this is a
dark day for america
lovely amen to that
take it away john i think that episode
ended off in the perfect cross section
of you and me with like me being like
you know what it's fine i'll stay silly
and you being like no i'ma go after that
revenge and make sure pacifica northwest
knows the truth
thought this episode was very much fun
i'm a sucker for silliness especially of
the cartoon varieties what are you
trying to say about me
uh i'm trying to say that you're gonna
get back at you right now
for putting me down in front of people
didn't mean to insinuate that you're not
silly
i'm very silly you
you know what you are i'm not still i'm
not you're i'm just saying yes to me
you're you're the silliest
you're i'm a silly man you're a goose
man
that's how silly you are
i'll prove it if i okay i take my
solutions very seriously yeah no no
please i i don't i don't want to cast
any doubt or make you feel like your
silliness yeah right adequate yeah no no
for sure for sure for sure dude you're
the silliest person i know
i swear
in fact i i was i was trying to inflate
my own sense of silliness and importance
by you know insinuating that i'm the
silly one around here when really we all
know that like i can't do a silly
for reals
yeah okay
all my silliness i just you know i i
learned from you
i'm ready to fall asleep i'm ready to
fall asleep okay good good then finish
your thoughts
this is a lot of fun this was a very fun
episode
uh i i i don't think that was stephen
colbert but yeah i i liked it was alex
hirsch i think it probably was there was
some grunkle stan in there um but yeah
i like you know i i'm a bit of a sucker
for that motif of like ah big conspiracy
it goes all the way to the top it's
something really dumb and silly but i
like that they just went full bore with
the fact that it is just about dumb
silliness is the whole reason for the
cover-up yeah uh and uh yeah the whole
mule like the pioneer day
thing you know it's a thing a lot of
towns in america have and do
uh so you know it's a nice little small
town flavorful setup here plus you get
the pun and the title irrational
treasure could have done with some more
nicholas cage references because the
only thing this episode was missing was
a good nicholas cage reference or two
but uh yeah it was a fun mystery and i
liked that you know mabel had that
journey of accepting her goofy silly
side i mean you know maybe not i don't
know i'm curious to hear your thoughts
because
at the outset you know i know the past
couple have had more of like a
this one had a personal uh you know kind
of story for mabel obviously of
self-acceptance but you know mostly is
about just the kind of grand scope of
all the silly things that are happening
um but thus uh even so i thought it was
a
solid quality episode
how about yourself did you enjoy it was
this in the mid mid tiers for you is
this a high tier episode
this is one of the worst episodes
i think it's one of the middle episodes
yeah uh for me about a little bit above
middle
um i think a child's journey of learning
to accept
one's
own
you know ability of
having fun
can be troubling especially in today's
culture of
a lot of the times
being free to be silly and have
you know fun is a big part of creativity
and expression and it it feels like as
we get older and then we behave more
serious
that
were that's a contributing factor to
repressing the
the child within us that sense of play
who use who needs to have resolve and
and i think in terms of
creativity and not caring about other
people's opinions as much uh you need to
be willing to not only be silly but
also to be stupid
and
you know because with with that in mind
you know it comes the ability to be
willing to fail and fail big and i think
a lot of
people as they get older they're taught
be serious quit being a kid grow up
when really i think the thing that a lot
of us gravitate towards is that
childlike ability
to wonder and be a little bit goofy and
not be taken so seriously because or not
take yourself so serious
so i i think on a purely psychological
level this is a very important episode
for our youth that should be taken more
serious
and you know what else
you said gravitate just then
yes we'll talk about growth yes because
i'm i'm being silly
i want people to know him that was very
silly
you know what show we're watching
yes we're watching gravity it's gravity
fall you said grab gravitate yes yes i
know i was i'm very much aware you know
those are based on the same root word
yes yes i'm aware i understand
vocabulary quite
quite good i'm sorry i was silly of me
to assume that you didn't and also
dealing with you know government
conspiracies and cover-ups which was a
real
problem that uh we have in the in the
world you know not trusting our citizens
to be able to handle the truth and the
real his history of what we
what we must endure you know when when
really we could learn from
the past
as long as it's rooted in the sense of
truth that's what counts
um so true absolutely i think there's a
lot of important messages to take away
in this one
and i i really did appreciate it and
also you know
dipper getting revenge in the end is not
something that i advise because it
usually it does not bring fulfillment
you know i believe it was franklin
sinatra who said
that
revenge
is a dish best no that was the klingons
yes
i believe it was franklin sinatra senior
who said
that um
the the best kind of revenge is massive
success
and usually by that point you're not
even thinking about
the revenge
quality to it um but yes you know it's
it's obviously
dipper and um
i'm sorry what is the little female's
name her name is
maybelle dipper and marble
the way
they deal with the it may it would it
would make sense to me that mabel would
absolutely struggle
with um you know
looking for validation from a bully in
her life because clearly these two
children suffer from abandonment issues
and
much neglect from their uncle you know
he is not
physically emotionally
truly available for those two and so
i can imagine that as mabel is getting
picked on
by her bully in some ways trying to
resolve
the issues that occur with her bully
in some ways is her standing up to
maybe her mother perhaps who has
left her behind
or even her uncle
uh for the insensitive ways of his
nature oh yeah but the the real root of
it was to solve it within herself
um so yes yes a lot of silliness that i
take in and from my observations it's
very
very silly
silly that's the best way to describe
it's all silly
you know what really silly is if we
tried to encase ourselves in some peanut
brittle and see if we can you know
preserve ourselves i was actually
wondering from a scientific level there
may be some facts
associated with peanut brittle as a way
to preserve life you know it it would
appear that with humanity one thing that
we have
failed to defeat is mortality yes the
fact that so the fact that life is so
precious and and and finite
yet no matter how much we through the
advancements of medicine
have been able to further the expansion
into the
average extension of a human being's
average lifespan
we have still not mastered the way to
preserve life forever to
create immortality and perhaps peanut
brittle
while presented as something humorous
there could be some actual ingredients
in there that do and it's something to
explore i don't i think as
you know i once had a science teacher
you had a science teacher too who's the
same one
who said you're all scientists if you
study science you're a scientist and and
i think that we should just uh feel
inspired we should be able to
you know perhaps look into it
no
hypothesis
is a silly one no
we are scientists we are all scientists
and we should embrace that and we should
you know use that title
use that title to prove that the
vaccination does not work oh it doesn't
no and neither do masks and neither does
social distance yes and also use science
to prove that it does help and work in a
lot of ways in preventative ways and
global warming is fake but it's also
kind of not fake in the
science yeah
and uh well there's no lies and numbers
that's how um
a great man once uh named peter parker
oh yeah who once encountered a magician
in another realm that is very difficult
to access but i was once able to access
this
was able to defeat magic with a geometry
oh dude so math you don't see that magic
triumphs mathematics a lot of the times
you know as the years have gone on we
have
simply
chalked things up to
you know that's how we've come up with
greek gods myths religion
yet a lot of times you can prove it
through science and math hey man um
geometry
is
a subject i am very much well-versed in
hey when all that stuff was being
theorized i bet a lot of people were
like what is this silliness
and now
after a little bit of perseverance that
silliness is math and science
well i say we end here on a upbeat
chipper note with a lot of charisma
subscribe and click that notification
bell and thank you to all who have
joined our patreon page and we will
catch you guys
i want to say soon but you know you
never know a car could hit john tomorrow
it's going to happen
and i have to pay that man a few hundred
dollars because that's how cheap it is
to have john off
how silly and how silly of them yeah
they're worth at least eight hundred i'm
worth at least eight hundred dollars for
the trouble
all right guys see
[Music]